we have long emphasized that open
borders have serious
national security implications joining
us now with analysis
retired cia senior intelligence officer
daniel hoffman
former member of the fbi joint terrorism
task force
steve rogers steve the tragic shooting
of a california police officer
by an illegal immigrant known gang
affiliations doesn't that underscore
that there are legitimate
safety and national security concerns at
risk here
which is why there needs to be not just
border security but a wall
it certainly proves president trump's
point greg look president trump has been
very consistent
he is making decisions based on national
security
two words that are not in the vocabulary
or the democrats so here we have a
president who's saying look
we're going to do everything we could to
stop the influx of of
of weapons of drugs of those things that
threaten national security
and let's keep one thing in mind too he
went to the border he talked to police
officers he talked to border agencies
he got their recommendations management
by walking around that was that's what
abe lincoln did
so president trump goes down gets the
recommendations of those who are being
confronted and challenged by criminals
and he made the decision
that's what has to be done the wall dan
hoffman
given your background with the cia talk
to us about
the safety and national security
concerns
that may be at risk without a wall
and without proper border security
so i think there's no question that
constructing a wall of strategic
locations with censors surveillance
and dedicated border patrol
can be a last line of defense against
transnational criminals and the
potential for terrorists
to use what is in some places a very
poorest border
i think there's other things we need to
do might from my experience at cia i
think we need to get out front of this
uh work with our mexican partners we've
had some pretty good collaboration with
them we need to hit the cartels pretty
hard
so that we reduce the drug flow into the
united states
and then separately we need e-verify so
that illegal aliens can't work here and
a visa tracking system because
roughly 40 percent of illegal aliens are
overstaying their visas
what i don't understand greg as a
citizen uh
i'm just chagrined at the breakdown and
legislative process if the cost
of of comprehensive immigration reform
is about five billion dollars i don't
understand why we just can't get it done
and i think as pam bondi said do a
little compromise
yeah but you know maybe it's coming down
to semantics
uh steve because the president wants a
wall
and some democrats are saying well
offense
would be okay i mean that's just a silly
semantical argument isn't it it sure is
and dan said something very interesting
that nobody wants to talk about the
potential of terrorists crossing that
border
with a weapon much much larger than a
rifle or a pistol
so i've got to give president trump a
lot of credit for having some vision and
some forethought
on maybe just preventing something like
that from happening that's why greg the
wall is important yeah dan
um you know i hear democrats uh and the
media
which i realize is redundant um say oh
you know you build a wall though that's
12 feet tall they'll get a 13 foot
ladder how do you respond to something
like that
i'm going to invoke the late charles
krauthammer who used to say that we need
to reduce the river of illegal
immigration to a trickle
is the war is the border wall a panacea
no is it going to stop all illegal
immigration no but it's going to reduce
it
and make it harder for illegal
immigration to take place in our country
and that'll de-incentivize people from
making what is an arduous journey
where many of them risk and sometimes
lose their lives
do we know of cases where terrorists
have come across the
southern border dan i think there's been
a lot of speculation i remember quite
well when the late senator john mccain
was grilling
dhs under secretary for intelligence
francis taylor back in 2015
about transnational criminals crossing
the border and
whether there have been terrorists who
were detected crossing that border
and honestly under secretary taylor
really didn't do a whole lot to convince
me that dhs
was able to detect whether terrorists
were crossing the border
or whether they in fact had in the at
some point in the past detected them
and regardless terrorists are always
looking for the soft spots
to exploit the vulnerabilities to
exploit
we know that from 9 11 and so if we see
a vulnerability best
to shut it down before someone exploits
it to their advantage and and and
uh again we don't want those threats uh
visited on our shores
yeah steve i see you nodding your head
at that you you agree completely
dan has got this nailed down because
ms-13 gang members are terrorists
and they're looking for avenues to get
into this country and without a wall
there it makes it much much easier for
them to get in and another point dan
made
look at you can get a strong door
there'll be a burglar be able to get in
that door
but it buys time it buys time for the
police to respond and to do what they
are trained to do
yeah i mentioned ladders and you know
not everybody can bring a ladder to the
wall and you're right
uh it's like a red flag you know we can
see that coming
uh dan steve thank you both for being
with us